if you ever run to a Korean lady I want
you to say I'll show you a nice word to
say that you're going to love right what
is it
yeah
I'm not gonna tell you what it means
right I want you to say to a Korean lady
okay they're gonna fall in love with you
bud I know a lot of Korean ladies I'm
big in the Kim good good good yeah yeah
yeah yeah when we went to Third Street
uh one of one of our good friends was a
Korean dude uh he was at the premiere
Roy Choi I know right we've done our
podcast yeah Roy is a good guy Roy lived
down the hall from me uh him and his
wife Jean and Kailyn their daughter and
uh they were staying at the [__]
hotel that we had the premiere party at
randomly and he was like with his
daughter and he was like yo birth
premieres like next door do you want to
go and so they came over to the premiere
and then we hung out with them all night
yeah awesome it's really crazy he told
me about I'm sure I've said this but
I'll say it again
he told me about
um the idea of starting kogi at
Thanksgiving we're at my house having
Thanksgiving dinner and he said I want
to I want to he was working at Rock
sugar at the time he was like I was
thinking about doing a taco truck wow
like a fusion taco truck like Korean
barbecue kind of like really make
something different and I was like I go
Brody can I be honest with you and he's
like what I was like that's the dumbest
idea I've ever heard in my [__] life
and he was like what and I was like did
you really do that I swear to God I said
a taco truck yeah a taco truck
I go Roy you got a family you got to
take go ask for that stuff oh really I
swear to God because I my friend
Wolfgang was like years ago was like a
pizza and I go you should do the pizza
were you guys at a hockey game and he's
like I just don't have a last name
how'd you know yeah yeah we're watching
the North Stars yeah playing and I go
Puck Puck yeah it's like thank you
um yeah I made I made white chili for
Tom Segura and Roy Choi one night he did
yeah
and it it's called for nine cans of
Chiles and I put nine cans of Jalapenos
in and I made a chili so bad that Roy
Choi left my apartment I said Roy help
me fix it and he looked at me and he
backed out of my apartment he goes I
can't help you and he left him dinner
whoa and then he came back and Tom and I
ate it us two fat [__] this one Tom was
like 290 315. wow and we just and we
were like we'll just have Tyree tomorrow
we're just gonna have diarrhea yeah yeah
it's uh it's uh yeah I'm what were we
talking about Korean people yeah yeah
why did Steve Byrne called me one time
and he was like hey everybody's Choice
are we just talking about Koreans right
now yeah yeah yeah let's just talk about
Korean let's see how long we just talk
about Korea oh let's do it okay yeah
yeah
um Steve Byrne called me one time and he
was like hey
I'm at Roy Choice taco truck what does
he look like and I guess yeah I know he
was with Vince Vaughn he was with Vince
Vaughn how do I know this I probably
told you this no no that's not he called
me too yeah yeah no he called me too I
swear to God this is how white Steve
Byrne is yeah he goes you know Roy Choi
and I go yeah and what does he look like
I swear to God I swear to God yeah me
too so that same night he was and then
did he ever run into I said to him he
looks like you but more hip-hop yeah I
didn't say that I said yeah
I said that too
yeah yeah yeah no it's so weird to dude
I swear to God I remember that because I
remember being mad like just wait in
line why Why You Vince Vaughn can't wait
in line what's with the update on your
beef with Vince Vaughn are you guys we
did a movie together I know but like was
it like just cordial or dude with Vince
Vaughn I did why I had beef with
everybody why I just
but when Vince and I did that short film
it was just him and I we had the most
magical glorious day and I what did you